right here with reaction foxnews
contributor trey gowdy Trey we have four
separate investigations FBI
investigation house Intel investigation
bipartisan set an investigation
something called the Muller report now
with all the talk about the rule of law
they ignored the Espionage Act
top-secret classified information on a
server bleach bit of the lesions and
hammers with subpoenaed emails and the
real Russian dossier bought and paid for
leaked to the media parts of it before
the election but used to deny Carter
page his civil liberties and spy on a
campaign transition team and presidency
how come they don't care about those
things
yes showing we we spent two years for
bomb or to tell us there was no evidence
at least two years for Mullard to tell
us there was no evidence of collusion it
took two minutes this time for us to
find out there was no evidence as soon
as a Republican asked this briefer than
the classified house Intel briefing what
evidence do you have to support that
assessment the answer was not so praise
the Lord it took two years last time it
took two minutes for over a year we were
lectured by the DC media and the
Democrats and no one is above the law
remember that child how many times we
heard no one's above the law apparently
accept whoever leaks classified
information out of Adam shifts committee
so what the Intelligence Committee needs
to give some thought to is stop briefing
someone who has a history and is an
epidemic leaker quit briefing him okay I
got a question so shift lie to the
American people Devin Nunez told the
truth to the American people we have
their both their documents Schiff lied
why doesn't he get held accountable for
lying the way he did to the American
public when he knew better
unfortunately Shawn it is not against
the law to lie to the American people
there should be a consequence and I hope
people and the People's Republic of
California will remember it come come
November but it's it's dirty little
secret it's not a crime for politicians
a lot of the American people but it is a
crime for you to lie to Congress
unbelievable all right congressman Gowdy
I don't think I want to race you in a
courtroom thank you